hello I'm Richard Beamer we won't see me
in your programs I'm your substitute
presenter I was just hanging around
backstage in my monkey suit hoping
somebody would fall out so I'd get my
chance I was sweeping the floor Adair
and lo and behold Jack Palance stumbled
and bumped his head on a broom handle
hmm seriously very seriously because
they're essentially inconsiderate
disasters are rarely give advance notice
earthquakes and volcanoes don't have
sneak previews however on one occasion
the newsreel cameras were there what a
disaster struck it was the arrival of
the Hindenburg at Lakehurst 40 years
later making a film of it apparently
created impossible problems
yes Yugi
that blend of reality and creativity has
earned a special award for visual and
sound effects from the Academy Board of
Governors to Albert Whitlock for his
matte paintings Glenn Robinson for his
miniature and yes and Peter berkos for
his sound effects
we would like to thank Robert Wise great
pleasure to work with as some of you
know and all at Universal especially
Bill Taylor
Dennis clowner Mike Marra Marco Mille
Weinbrenner Larry Shula and said Dutton
and our thanks to the Academy for this
to us a very special award we'd also
like to thank the Academy mr. Donna felt
mr. Karr Fang new Christine and Bob Beck
and Frank Randall and the crew that made
it possible thank you I want to share
this recognition with my crew George
Luckenbach er Sam Renaud's and Hal
Gordon and I want to thank the Motion
Picture Academy for this very special
Oscar and recognition of the sound
editors creative contribution of motion
pictures and to mr. Bob Weiss thank you
for the assignment